i have said for a long time on this show
that the left through political
correctness or wokeness or cancer
culture or whatever
is seeking purely to destroy to
dismantle to deconstruct this is not a
positive movement
trying to build something it's just
trying to tear stuff down
and sometimes left-wingers say michael
that's not fair no
you're straw manning that's not true
well one social justice warrior with a
podcast
kim brown her show is called burn it
down with kim brown i think you can get
the thesis of what that is
she is acknowledging that what we're
seeing right now in leftist activism
is purely designed to destroy
i support all that i support them
looting
the the damn dollar tree i support the
looting of
uh what are the [ __ ] today loot uh like
the like the advanced auto parts
um i remember last year they looted
target i support all that
loot all that do you know why because
black people and
marginalized and oppressed people could
loot every store
in this whole country for 200 years it
would not even come close
to the debt that america owes us
but of course that's not true america
doesn't owe any people or any people's
anything nothing nunc niente nada
this is true of the west more broadly
the west though
though the west flagellates itself and
says oh i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
the west does not owe anybody anything
the west produced
the greatest civilization in the history
of the world which has been
an un fathomable blessing
to the entire globe unfortunately the
opinion that america and the west
owe something to everybody else has
gained a lot of currency on the left it
has come
to dominate our national conversation
we're only focusing
on these screaming radical leftists
i hate to be a kicker i always long for
peace but the wheel that squeaks the
loudest
is the one that gets the grease hey
smash that like button subscribe hit the
bell
so that you do not miss any content from
the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Music]